>> Tucker: BACK IN JANUARY,
SENATOR JOSH HAWLEY OF MISSOURI
DID WHAT MANY DEMOCRATS HAVE
DONE TO KEEP VOTED AGAINST
CERTIFYING THE RESULTS EIGHT
REVIEW PICU -- -- DEMOCRATS
DEMANDED HIS EXPULSION FROM
CONGRESS.
THEN HIS PUBLISHER SUGGESTED
THAT HE WAS SOMEHOW AN ACCESSORY
TO VIOLENCE.
THEY CANCELED HIS BOOK CONTRACT.
IT WAS ABOUT THE DANGER OF BIG
MEDIA COMPANIES.
AFTER THIS HAPPENED, WE INVITED
JOSH HAWLEY TO TALK ABOUT IT.
THE PEOPLE ARE SO CRAZED WITH
IDEOLOGY THAT THEY CAN'T BEAR TO
HEAR -- WHAT DOES THAT PRETEND
FOR THE COUNTRY?
>> I THINK THAT WE ARE IN A
PERIOD WHERE THE FIRST AMENDMENT
VALUES AND CRYSTALS OF --
PRINCIPLES OF FREEDOM OF SPEECH
ARE UNDER ATTACK.
I COME BACK BACK TO THE FACT
THAT THIS IS SOMETHING THE FIRST
AMENDMENT IS SOMETHING THAT
UNITES US AS AMERICANS.
AT THIS TIME, IT IS OF DIVISION
AND THIS TIME OF CHAOS, WE GOT
TO STAND STRONG FOR THAT.
>> Sean: SIMON & SCHUSTER IS
NOT THE GOVERNMENT.
IT IS A PRIVATE COMPANY.
BUT HIS POINT OF THE FIRST
AMENDMENT IS REAL QUICK BUT FOR
ME PERSONALLY, WHAT HAPPENED TO
JOSH HAWLEY WITH MORE THAN AN
ACADEMIC QUESTION.
AT THE TIME HIS BOOK WAS
CANCELED, I WAS ALSO UNDER
CONTRACT TO PRODUCE A BOOK FOR
SIMON & SCHUSTER.
THEY WERE PAYING ME TO DO IT,
BUT IT SEEMS CURRENTLY NOT TO
ADDRESS IT QUICKLY.
I CALLED THE CEO OF THE COMPANY
AND I TOLD HIM THAT I THOUGHT
CANCELING A BOOK FOR PARTISAN
REASONS WAS DISCUSSING AND WRONG
AND IT SET A VERY BAD PRESIDENT.
I TOLD HIM I WANTED TO WRITE
ABOUT WHAT HE HAD BEEN IN MY NEW
BOOK AS A KIND OF SNAPSHOT OF
WHAT WAS HAPPENING ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
I STARTED TO REPORT ON IT.
I INTERVIEWED JOHN AND OTHER
SIMON & SCHUSTER EXECUTIVES.
I ASKED THEM UNDER WHAT
CIRCUMSTANCES ARE YOU WILLING TO
BUT SINCE WITH THE POLITICAL
VIEWS OF YOUR AUTHORS?
IT TURNED OUT TO BE AN AMAZING
SERIES OF CONVERSATIONS.
THEY WERE HIGHLY UNCOMFORTABLE,
AS YOU CAN IMAGINE.
, BUT FASCINATING PUT THEIR
ANSWERS, SOME OF THEM HONEST,
SOME OF THEM LIES, IT REVEALED
IN THE CLEAREST POSSIBLE WAVE
HOW CORPORATE AMERICA UNDERMINED
FREE SPEECH.
SIMON & SCHUSTER CONFIRMED THAT
THEY WILL PUBLISH MY ACCOUNT OF
THEIR CENSORSHIP.
THE CEO JOHN KARP, SAID HE WILL
COME ON THE SHELF AND ATTEMPT TO
JUSTIFY IT.
WE ASSUME HE WILL KEEP HIS WORD.